المنطقه بتاع غرب افريقيا تشهد حراكا
دبلوماسيا سياسيا محموما
دخول الاشقاء النيجيريين حافظوا على
الارواح ما تعطوش فرصه للناس
[موسيقى]
ابلغته رساله من لدنه تتعلق اساسا بالازمه
في النيجر
وافاق تكثيف
وتوحيد جهودنا لترقيه اسس حل سلبي يجنب
هذا البلد والمنطقه برمتها
تداعيات التصعيد المحتمل للاوضاع
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي وصل
الى نفس التقييم وهو انه الان سياسه فرنسا
في ازمه وحتى المقاربه الفرنسيه للخروج من
هذه الازمه يعني
في في صعوبه كبيره
[موسيقى]
تم تهديد مباشر
حنا رافضين رفض تام وقطعي بالنسبه للتدخل
العسكري لحل المشاكل التي هي احسن
في انقلاب احنا قلنا
رانا مع الشرعيه الدستوريه ولازم يرجعوا
للشرعيه الدستوريه